hello folks and welcome back to
GameSpot's continuing coverage of e3
2014 you're watching the Samsung sage
right here on GameSpot calm I'm your
host Daniel two-wire for the next couple
of demos and I'm very happy to be joined
by Michael the platter sir monolith you
guys are working on this crazy
middle-earth game that people are pretty
excited about yeah III he's been amazing
actually giving people getting their
hands on it getting all of the feedback
it's been phenomenal really great so for
anyone who hasn't seen a shadow of
Mordor explain that what exactly it is
because I think it's actually quite
surprising what type of game it is it's
it's a third-person open world
action-adventure game and it takes place
after the end of The Hobbit so Sirhan's
been defeated by the white council
driven out of dull gold Lords after the
end of the Battle of five our miners
sorry if you don't really back that's a
spoiler and but it's still six decades
before the war of the ring so sarin's
just returned home to Mordor and his
return kind of obviously is a pretty
dramatic event in Mordor and for that
past two millennia while he's been away
the ranges of Gondor have been been
guarding it and when he returned they're
all slaughtered including the character
you play Italian but then you're
resurrected by a spirit of vengeance
that also awakened by Sharon's return
and has a very sort of deep ancient
grudge against our own and yes together
the two of you kind of head behind enemy
lines to take on the Dark Lord's forces
and that's what we saw in there some of
the CG trailer that you you released as
well we're looking at a trailer right
here actually a kid so tell us a little
bit the main character he's kind of like
how he's half rape half warrior so he
really is the embodiment of these two
characters I nearly slipped and gave a
spoil of him that was close the Wraith
himself is this very powerful character
from the law strong connection with
Sirhan's from connection with the rings
of power and all those sort of ideas of
power and what that means
whereas tallien is someone who
effectively has been cursed by being
bound to this rate so he begins the game
very much in the same situation as the
player he's unsure of why it is he
doesn't understand why
he's not said why he hasn't been allowed
to find peace in in death and in order
to discover that uncover it and also
pursue the guys responsible for his
death and the death of his family he has
to travel together with this Wraith and
kind of unravel that mystery so let's
talk about the bones of the game the
actual momentum I won't play
I guess Florida Rings games has been a
couple of them they've been
predominantly tied to the series itself
of movies they've been character action
games where you are essentially
following the plot a linear plot of the
movies and this is a much more open
experience can you explain just how open
it is right from the get-go when when
you start playing yeah it's a good
question I think that the two parts to
that one we absolutely didn't want to be
a movie game you know I think that's
definitely something with Warner
Brothers with our brief right from the
beginning if you've got this benchmark
of that you know the right way to treat
a license is to do the best possible
game you can do and not to do a movie
they've been the case with the Batman
stuff as well yeah absolutely and of
course you know they're a big
inspiration and they really just set
this incredibly high bar to aim towards
but and and then with the Hobbit and
Lord of the Rings themselves with those
stories they're these amazing standalone
stories that you can enjoy on their own
or as part of the kind of Greater
history of middle-earth and so we really
wanted to do that as well to have a
standalone story that can be enjoyed
whether it's you know your first entry
in the Middle Earth or whether you are
incredibly hardcore into every detail of
the law in history making it accessible
from all of those different directions
and of course in the same way you know
the books are these incredible stories
but within a universe like that what's
exciting is the the possibility of
getting to actually explore it getting
to create your own stories and that's
what games as a medium can bring that no
other medium can that's the one big
strength that we have so it was
extremely important to create an
open-world game give players the freedom
to actually explore create their own
stories so is that world is it is it a
completely open from the Star
obviously there is a narrative thread
throughout the game and there's a quest
to be completed but are there can you
approach them in an order you you
perceive to be what you want to do or
other side quests just what are we
talking because open-world is quite a
scalable thing right now yep so the
world is divided into zones it's not
entirely continuous but within each zone
with each each area of the world you're
completely free to go and pursue it in
the order that you want and the two that
we've shown we've shown you dune which
is cinder and for hell that's the the
opening area of the game when you are
resurrected and awakened on the other
side and the black gates and then here
at e3 we're also revealing the nirn
which is another region it's many sort
of hundreds of miles deeper into Mordor
behind enemy lines and it's a very sort
of different area model much more lush
and so on but and so then within those
you can pursue different side stories in
whatever order you want you know one of
the things we were very very excited
about what's working with Christian
Canada meza so he's the the lead writer
lead designer on Red Dead and that
inspiration of having these amazing
characters and side stories that you can
meet within the world and you can go and
pursue those so that you know the main
story paths not not linear but then our
big innovation is we focused very very
much on our enemies in the stories you
can create with your own personal
enemies yes I remember it was it earlier
this year perhaps at the tail end of
last year now you guys show it off
what's what's I think is it known as the
Nemesis system it's essentially this
this way of having a degree of history
with with the enemies in the game it's
it's a combination like I think our two
goals were to you know it's an action
game and so so much of what defines what
you do in an action game is your
interaction and combat and contesting
against your enemies and yeah so at the
bottom end we didn't want to have
generic cannon fodder because there's
only so much of that you can do before
we get inside so we wanted to make every
enemy you encounter represent a
possibility for all sorts of things
could have
whether you can interrogate them to get
information bend them to your will
create missions they can defeat you you
know so every encounter can can have the
seeds of all sorts of possibilities and
stories and then at the other end the
bosses the ultimate bad guys that you're
going to have a personal grudge with we
wanted to make that personal so these
guys are going to grow they're going to
remember they're going to gain their own
skills they're actually living within
the the sort of the open world pursuing
their own missions and and so as they
interact with you as the play you're
building up these stories so because
model is just incredibly dangerous place
and orc society is so driven by violence
and competition and of Orcs society yeah
it's it's an all social simulator this
really incident and it sort of makes the
most brutal prison yard you could
imagine tan by comparison everything
sold by violence so they're fighting
against each other to rise through the
ranks so being able to get into the
middle of that and basically in a way
you almost you know playing this
simulator from the inside through
through your actions but then having it
remember and acknowledge that and and
speak back to you and then you know
that's what's been so exciting here at
e3 is that every single person that
plays gets to have a disparate
differential variance and it is
interesting from that I remember I think
it was maybe the second reveal you
showed a perhaps it was that first one
is very strong it was it was showing the
ability to you know you can either run
in and do your bloodbath thing or like
setting interacting with one of them and
we're setting the stage for admission
way further in the future maybe you
could influence one of the orcs to the
stage where they could almost cheat
their way through the final mission
later on yeah how hard is it creating
those systems knowing that you were
trying to enable the player to do those
things without giving them too much of a
foreshadowing of what couldn't happen in
the future because it must be hard to
you know the immediacy of just chopping
somebody's head off is right there so
how do you encourage the player to try
and work it that sort of almost
subversive diplomacy within the game
yes I think there's that there's a few
ways one is
by just supporting a very very rich and
dynamic ecosystem so you've got monsters
turning up if alarms go off things can
get very crazy very quickly you've got
opportunities in the environment to
incinerate these guys or unleash swarms
of biting flies or have you know walls
collapse on them so there's cons there's
a load of different ways they can
possibly die plus the morale system is
very dynamic these guys have to be smart
enough not to just stand there and let
you kill them when things are turning
against them in the midst of this chaos
like any good villains they're going to
actively try and live to fight another
day so they really are you know like
like any villain does you trying to
engineer a series of encounters with you
trying to jump out an ambush you when
you're weakest trying to follow you only
being drawn out by you within areas
where they feel safe chance yeah so it's
not it's it's kind of without geeking
out too much but it's sort of ear free
it's an AI Dungeon Master it's not like
we're trying to create a totally
chessboard simulation we're trying to
create a system that actually does build
stories build memorable moments let you
engineer all of this chaos and then you
know because another thing that's a big
motivation people love to record and
share and talk about the stories of the
of their most memorable and epic moments
whatever the game is could be a sports
game strategy game whatever but within
the game itself we can use the enemies
as the way to acknowledge that let you
know that we've seen this awesome stuff
happen and pay it off and then give you
the satisfaction of doubling down on
that by you know getting revenge or
building a grudge against this guy or
bending him to your will so it's it's
really letting players create their own
stories and then wrapping them in the
the narrative of the world so it's
really immersive what I like about it is
that that even seems from a personnel
standpoint on this project to be the
case you have priors with creative
assembly working on the Rome series and
this has been developed by monolith who
are a team that have made some of the
most immersive first-person games like
I'm a big fan of condemned fear and like
you want to go for as far back as blood
which is a
first person game I mentioned and people
don't like don't even remember what it
was but those really sort of rich in
farms you you say that the the lead
writer on red dead is involved as well
is it the fact that you're making a game
that is very mechanically clever but
then you're sort of just you're trying
to keep those mecan't you're layering
it's almost like that marriage of ours
and technical that's exactly what yes
because it because this game for you and
for a lot of those guys it's a
third-person action game so it's kind of
not necessarily in your safe zone either
now which is great I mean the reason
that there are no safe zones anymore
you've only gonna you know go for it or
give up but and and so I think you know
we're in a situation where we had to
kind of by definition try something new
and something ambitious and and try is
very much a model if game you know play
to the strengths of the team which is
the AI which is you know the great
writing which is layering in this
storytelling which is I think this
combination of there's certainly some
darkness but there's some humor
yeah and bringing that sort of character
and atmosphere to it so you know it's
been just such a learning process for me
to work with these guys and and to learn
so much from the team as well and then
also I think you know be able to bring
some influences from even other genres
so it you know sports games and strategy
games which are games about making
systems to to create and tell a story
and when we can put those two things
together to have these systems but then
to have that that flavor kind of
visceral action and that humor in that
atmosphere and hopefully try to kind of
bring all that together that's create
something that I think's pretty unique
awesome I got the platter thank you so
much thank you you and for the folks I
don't one more time could you let them
know when when it's out and on my
platforms
absolutely so shadow moto is coming out
on October the 7th and it's going to be
on PlayStation 4 Xbox one PC Xbox 360
and PlayStation 3 and I got a lot of
work to do yes you do
go back into well actually there's a lot
of guys there right now doing that work
alright I hope they're enjoying this
stream taking a little bit of a break
off and Michael thank you so much for
joining us we got a bunch more stuff
left up here in Tucson some stage I know
code name Steve
and now Scott we gotta seen that check
and I'm guessing it's guessing it's
Ashley there might be Jeff Bakalar we'll
find out in just a second